[Music]
look at this
spectate bug from the coach like how is
this even possible this is go you need
to fix this
i've got this game loaded up it's heroic
versus astralis
it's the match we're hunting for the
first 10 rounds had a coach camera
or had a camera and free cam on banana
all professional counter-strike played
in the last three years can pretty much
be thrown right in the trash that's my
hot take
37 coaches have been banned at the
professional level of counter-strike
for exploiting a glitch that allowed
them to get information
they should not have had if every case
is a case
but we're dealing with a mass problem
here
mijo slovinsky was on vacation when he
realized that cs go had a huge
problem see for most of 2020 he worked
as a freelance cs go referee for esl
and in june people started messaging him
about an in-game coaching exploit that
was
apparently being abused at the highest
levels of counter-strike
let me maybe quickly explain the whole
story and how it began
start from the beginning at some point
in june this year i had um received few
reports that there is um this bug
that allows coaches to see enemies on
the map if it was true it would be huge
dozens of top teams could have been
cheating in high level tournaments the
only problem was
as is often the case in cs go there
wasn't any solid proof
honestly um the explanation provided was
not very clear
um people didn't even know how it works
exactly or
how to reproduce it and usually that's
the most important thing right being
able to reproduce it
mihao decided to dig deeper and actually
found a few examples of the bug in
action
he recorded it and fired off an email to
valve about what he'd found
um but with this bug you were able to
potentially get yourself stuck in any
position on the map whether that was in
the sky on
one of the spawns or um like at one of
the bomb sites
and you were able to basically get stuck
in that position for the entire match
and
observe what's going on from from the
sky right to be clear
that bug would have given any team that
used it a huge advantage
it offered a ton of information and
could completely unbalance a map
but with the email sent mihao thought
his job was done
and he could go back to his much needed
vacation but while he was on vacation
the thought that maybe just maybe
coaches were cheating at the highest
levels of competitive counter-strike
kept him up at night throughout 2020
mihao worked on some of the biggest cs
go tournaments of the year
and he couldn't stand the thought of
someone cheating at an event that he
refereed
so he started scrubbing through demos
going all the way back to march 2020
and what he found changed everything
at the start of august i started going
through some demos
and verifying a few of my suspects
ironically
none of the people i suspected actually
well i was basically wrong about all of
them and but by checking
virtus pro coach dastan who is a very
punctual guy
um so big big respect to him for that i
came across uh mikhailogan who
turned out to be the worst abuser um i
think that's when i realized this is
real and that's when i realized this is
a big big problem meccano gun was the
coach for hard legion throughout 2020
a middling team without a ton of
competitive prospects but
he was far from the biggest name that
mihao found out about i've got this game
loaded up
it's heroic versus astralis it's the
match where hunden for the first 10
rounds
uh had a coach camera or had a camera
and free cam on banana i mean how has
the research led to tons of cheaters
being found out
even a hundred heroics coach and a long
time cs player
if heroic were cheating who else was i
thought
this is something i needed to do i
thought this is my job
you know i was i was really worried that
there could have been a cheating
incident
during one of the events that i covered
like i i walked on as an admin
it just bothered me it honestly just
bothered me it just felt like the the
right thing to do and
and so i decided to to go through all of
the demos
from all of the tournaments that i
walked on between march and july
obviously um after that you know i was
kind of in a zone so i was like okay
let's let's check all of the big events
in 2020 right
with his decision made me how got to
work and scrubbed through 2
000 demos building a database of
information without being paid for any
of it
but he quickly realized that there was
simply too much footage to go through by
himself
i needed a second opinion and i wanted
to keep this undercover
for now so in this case steve was the
perfect go-to
now the main reason why i wanted to keep
it uh on the cover is because
i didn't want to throw any accusations
around without having that hundred
twenty percent confidence right i knew
that this could
um ruin um someone's reputation or even
you know a life someone's life so i had
to be 120
sure that before reporting anywhere
enter steve dudenhoffer a senior
developer for esea
and a friend of mihawk one exploit two
guys and
15 terabytes of data mihao says that if
he and steve made going through demos
their full-time job
it still would have taken them years to
scrub through everything
so what the hell were they supposed to
do towards the end of august
steve created something else he created
like a demo
parser that analyzed analyze demos by
checking
the location of every coach and it
basically compared it to the location of
all the players
but i think in the end when we applied
all of these
filters that steve created i think we
managed
to narrow down the list from just over a
hundred thousand
um demos to around thirty thousand demos
okay but now they had a list so what
comes next
first meehau tweeted out his findings um
one of the reasons why i went
with essec for you know for the most of
the investigation is because
i thought the way i was um releasing
these clips
was wrong in a way um it's it's not why
intended i just didn't realize
that you know this is bad so that's why
i decided to go with someone who
obviously has who has not only resources
but also
a little bit more knowledge about you
know penalize in these cases right
the esic or esports integrity commission
is an organization that's dedicated to
among other things investigating
cheating in esports and handing out
recommendations to tournament organizers
you've got to think of it a little bit
like a wall hack right it just
that's what it is in in effect and
that's how you can use it and and we
certainly know from previous cases and
stuff i've dealt with that
if you detected a player using a wall
hack
there'd be zero doubt across the
community
that a let's say a two-year ban for
cheating was
more than justified the esic are
actually a pretty tiny organization
they have a small budget and most of
their staff are volunteers
so sorting through 15 terabytes of cs go
demos
was not going to be easy it was going to
take time
oh no to the lion's den and boris
quad kill for grand final point for the
trophy
this is the first cologne for borap
cadion
texas and they're the last team standing
unbelievable
on august 31st the day after heroic won
esl one cologne europe
the first wave of the esic investigation
crashed down
cs go fans finally found out that yes
there was cheating going on
at the highest levels of counter-strike
we're as close to a sport as you can
possibly get in terms of esports
competitive integrity integrity is the
most important thing that we have at
this point
once people don't trust what they're
watching everything else is out the
window and so that must be protected at
all costs
and that's whether it's match fixing
cheating
a coach bug like this which is so
powerful all those things are equally
important
three coaches 23 accusations and 50
months
in total bands as summer turned to fall
the backlash that mihao was expecting
the whole time
never materialized in fact the community
seemed thankful for the work that he and
steve did
sponge and stunna even started a
gofundme to pay me how and steve back
for all the work they did
so far the cs go community has raised
over thousand dollars as a sort of thank
you
yeah i mean absolutely community support
in this has been
overwhelming to say at least right now
um we received thousands of positive
messages from random people we received
a lot of praise from
colleagues players talent you know on
top of that there was the fundraiser
it's honestly incredible and people like
to focus on negatives but let me tell
you that those negatives
was like 10 20 messages it's it's
honestly nothing in comparison to
to all the positive messages by
september 37 coaches were banned
some only got hit with short three-month
bans while meccano gun got a two-year
ban
and that's as you can see where we kind
of went look we
we can't hang pundin dead and meccano
gun out dry on this
in isolation when we know that there are
a hell of a lot
more guys abusing this over the past
five years it would that wouldn't you
know
that didn't sit well with me it was the
biggest cheating scandal in cs go
history
but cs go survived and me how wouldn't
change
a thing cs go made it through a massive
controversy and arguably
it's even stronger than before rpk
towards flat and navera finds timing on
that first peak
but rpk's ak can they get the better of
it oh he goes
right back out fade away damn that was
amazing from rpk
now that first report only summarized
about 20 of me how and steve's data
the esic says there's more to come but
remember there's a lot of work to do so
it could take some time but mihao's role
in this investigation ended in october
so
now he's just waiting for the results
like the rest of us are as cs go fans
who want the game to thrive
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this
hit the sub button and ring that
notification bell for unique bite size
videos you won't find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages